e oggi andremo a fare lambo xing del
nostro mega regalo di natale
precedentemente che cosa è successo che
ha comunque usato per evitare il video
per fare varie cose e più sono curiosa
di provare a disegnare con la apple
pensili non ho mai disegnato con la pole
pencil anch'io solo questo che disegno
benissimo
figli andremo a fare lambo xing disse
che io adoro e video unboxing che voi
piacciono tantissimo
andiamo fare la mossa in sé delle
ipotesi della pole pensile poi proviamo
a disegnare pronti i primi doveri premi
il poc
la sciabolata relax e iniziamo subito
allora iniziamo con l'apertura della
apple pencil che purtroppo va comprato a
separatamente mannaggia questa è la
scatola tipica scatola apple molto
semplice quindi hanno fatto le linguette
da poco mi sta per togliere il packaging
più velocemente
infatti ogni volta bisogna litigare per
togliere tutte le cose di plastica con
taglierino forbici almeno così pare a
procedimento perché non far meglio un
box senso ma anche un po sm
allora si apre a faccia un'altra
linguetta
design by apple in california
ed ecco fa la penna teniamo fa cosa c'è
piaceranno libretto di istruzioni il
solito bloc party sono un po di
istruzioni
e la penna e qua anche la penna è
incartata oddio appoggiava favore di
rompere tutto ecco qua la penna più
costosa al mondo incredibile alla punta
è un po morfica guarda
www beh penso per scivolare bene sullo
schermo quindi questa è la apple pencil
fa allora dimora aprire l'ipad questa è
la versione leggermente più piccola
quindi leggermente meno posto nella da
11 11 e rame sembra dietro su scritto pc
insomma wifi
caspita
[Applauso]
apple e senza stop
andiamo a sezionare la linguetta verrà
prima no hanno questo sia precisi adesso
mi ha detto niente non prenderlo dai
lati da qui e da qui mi all'interno del
teatro le ragazze guida un volto in
finisce qua no
la penna l'hanno fatta così intuitivo ad
aprire ma questa estate quattro volte in
funzione unboxing delle asperità allora
ecco qua lo schermo opaco perché non
ipad così lasciato c'è la pellicola
anche qua un no vabbè leggerissimo
iscrivermi le prendi zero allora
togliamo la pellicola
ma perché tu possa ferire il colore ma
lo hanno cambiato diversamente pareti
che lo ammira telo pulito perché poi
sarà piena di vita te a circa 26 void
pienissimo digitate quindi questo il
nuovo pro e appunto a schermo pieno non
ha quindi qua dietro il loro è
abbastanza grande e anche troppo e poi 4
la camera allora prova ad accenderlo e
io nel frattempo vedo questa somma come
si accende per sé stante che seppur
allora qua si sono le tipiche istruzioni
[Applauso]
ecco qua come sfruttare facebook i
soliti sticker a questi mi sembrano più
grandi delle solite e altre istruzioni
poi il caricatore sembra un caricatore
veloce questo sì molto grande sì anche
perché con a usb c quindi essere al
caricatore veloce e poi il cavo per
caricarlo bello e basta tutti gli altri
capi li dovrò comprare separatamente
non c'è più niente solo le sembra fiale
calabrese potresti mettere e col
potresti mettere qualche regalino vedo
ogni tanto delle forze oppure sì la
penna teso ora dobbiamo fare il setup
allora facciamo velocemente setup e poi
proviamo a disegnare ok abbiamo fatto
l'agcom privo reazione e abbiamo
configurato anche la bella ora sono in
una pagina vuota di pages non so perché
ma non mi fa cambiare colore alla matita
e ragione allora mettiamo un viola e
proviamo prima prova a scrivere qualcosa
o non vuole fare disegno immagino sono
gesso disegno
frey fa prima bisognava aggiungere il
foglio o meno male ok
wow ma come scrivere tranne che è super
liscia la superficie e scivola molto di
più
obama degli orrendi provo bravissimo e
super rapido però la superficie essendo
così liscia si vola un sacco disegnini
vuole fissile anche attore cattolici
prova gli altri mancato nei arancione
[Musica]
vogliono colorare tutto vabbè io non
sono bravo a disegnare voglio sapere
perché avete visto i miei disegni adesso
evitare una smette più di stime perché
non è bravo e senza matricola e colorare
e disegnare poiché avevo dolore di
facciamo le vecchiette rosa del settore
tutta giallo
il primo di denise hillary vitale e poi
con i colori più bello
dove devo capire come funziona non ci
siamo beh cambiamo reply a san vitaliano
si stacca per il semplice con questo
richiamo nota invece questa dovrebbe
essere per scrivere infatti scrive più
piccolo figo
vediamo la matita la vera notizia fosse
treni di più forte e ci passi sopra fa
tipo la sfumatura della matita vedi a
saper disegnare perfetto infatti però
possiamo scrivere allora voglio provare
adesso ho scaricato acqua se no con page
o scaricato photoshop
vediamo se riusciamo a fare qualcosa
bene ragazzi allora stavo girando un po
cercando delle auto ma devo vedere
meglio che up scaricare quindi vi
ringrazio per aver guardato questo video
potete sapere se volete vedere magari in
cassazione il mio ipad una volta che ho
scaricato tutte le app più divertenti
per disegnare o modificare le foto
insomma fatemi sapere nei commenti su di
un bel live se volete vedere altri video
unboxing e ora vi lasciamo qua quattro
date linee su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri vi i nostri video
divertenti shopping challenge con la
ruota cliccati in quello che preferite e
buona